-Finally, guys, as I mentioned,
Harry Styles' new album,
"Harry's House,"
was released today.
So with that in mind,
it's time to play
Guess the Harry Styles Song.
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Guess the Harry Styles song ♪
♪ Guess that song ♪
Now, here's how this works.
I'm going to give someone
three different
song titles.
One is a real Harry Styles song
off the new album.
The other two are made up.
You have to guess
which one is real.
If you get it right,
you get a prize.
If you get it wrong,
you still get a prize.
Okay.
Raise your hand
if you want to play
Guess the Harry Styles Song.
Let's try that guy right there
in the front, in the third row.
Yeah, you, stand up. Hello.
Welcome. What is your name?
-Christina.
-Christina. Welcome. All right,
Christina, which one of these
is a real Harry Styles song
from his new album,
"Harry's House?"
Is it...
-It's "B."
-It is "B." You think,
"Music for a Sushi Restaurant?"
-Yeah.
-That is correct.
But...
That is correct,
but you just won
a "Music for a dentist's
waiting room" sweatshirt.
-Congratulations to you.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right, let's get
another person.
Put your hand up.
All the way in the back.
The gentleman in the back
right there
with the black facemask there,
yeah.
Hello, sir. What is your name?
-Tom Clemens.
Where are you from, Tom?
-Nashville, Tennessee.
-Hey. Nashville.
We love Nashville.
We love Tennessee. All right.
Which one of these
is a real Harry Styles song?
Is it...
-Got to go with the Goose Juice.
-Yeah.
Can you sing a little of
how you think the song goes?
-Uh, ♪ Watermelon sugar,
goose juice? ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That sounds about right.
That is incorrect.
But you still get a Goose Juice
sweatshirt right there for you.
Go Goose Juice!
[ Cheers and applause ]
All the way.
But -- All right, one more.
Put your hand up over here.
Yes, right there.
Right there.
Yes, you right there.
Of course. Right there.
What is your name?
-Alicia.
-Alicia, where are you from?
-New Milford, Connecticut.
-Ah, hey, New Milford.
Welcome. Welcome.
Connecticut.
Which one of these
is a real Harry Styles song?
Is it...
-"A," Daydreaming?
-That is correct.
It is "Daydreaming."
[ Bell dings ]
And you receive a "rabbit-shaped
cloud" sweatshirt!
Congratulations.
Thank you for playing
Guess the Harry Styles songs.